i used my detective skills as well as my
spot on holt impression to figure it out
i just had an idea peralta you're
a genius who is that scarjo it was holt
and i think you know that i thought i
was scared
amazingly wearing holt's clothes is our
best option everyone
prepare to enter high society
okay how's everybody feeling anyone else
have the weird urge to lecture
themselves
peralta what are you doing peralta what
are you doing
i conjured him she's not here
damn it stop thinking about her like
she's your girlfriend what would you do
if she was a perp i guess
role play try and see the world through
her eyes oh no
what if i see my reflection and fall in
love with myself jake we have a literal
ticking clock situation here roger that
okay fine i'll be amy just know
everything i'm about to say i say with
love
okay i'm outside it's 78 degrees and yet
somehow
i'm still cold better walk on the sunny
side of the street
wait did i remember to put on sunscreen
pause the thing pause to think yes i did
put on sunscreen and i bragged about it
all morning amy's on the move and i'm
walking i'm walking
okay so captain holt leaves fencing and
heads north
if we really want to do this we got to
get in his head we have to be
captain holt hello gina
how does this sound captain holt is that
you
oh no it's jake nailing your voice
exactly
right the trick is to find a key phrase
you know exactly how he'd say
mine is peralta that's enough seriously
jake this is getting scary
come with me young wise assistant let us
walk in this direction
oh a hot dog would i stop
not for one of those i wouldn't damn it
it's morphing into british do your
catchphrase peralta that's enough
and i'm walking with purpose and i'm
walking with purpose
and bingo a door
it's a narnia situation no but i love
that
it's a security camera if something
happened to hold when you walk past here
we'll be able to see it
peralta you genius hmm that does not
sound like him
lighten up your jacket sit up straight
judge mendel has a reputation for being
strict and proper
all right no worries i'll just act like
you say something so i can get the
cadence of your voice down
i will not perfect i will not i
will not i will not
okay so you guys are rich europeans
looking about shelby
i'll make the introductions wait we
can't just be europeans what country are
we from what languages do you speak
french spanish some portuguese
obviously greek enough flemish to get by
tight what about you peralta
um i can do a pretty good italian accent
you think you could milk me
so you're just doing de niro from meet
the parents i don't know am i
this is dinero i think it's pretty good
now mine's better
pretty good we'll just make america okay
i'm walking
i'm walking and i'm seeing a paper
supply store
i wonder if they have those new summer
folders whoa you're good i've definitely
heard her talk about those folders
that's because they have such a fun
color scheme perfect for vacation
organization
this is chilling darn it to heck
the store is closed my bad day just got
a whole heck of a lot
worse time to go smoking secret
[Music]
and as i'm shame-smoking i'm seeing
the library i think maybe i have a way
to put kevin in danger without putting
kevin in danger
well hello there raymond teach me kevin
and i am detective jacob peralta he
didn't have anything else to wear so he
just switched
he understands okay if we're gonna pull
this off we need to teach you how to
move
talk and act exactly like kevin in other
words we have ourselves a pygmalion
situation
exactly a pig mailman situation right
it'll be okay well it'll be okay let's
get started yes
let's get started it's getting worse
spot on kevin
look raymond a yellow-crusted warbler a
greymund
a yellow-crested warbler no you're too
excited the warbler is a common bird
and then i said which metamorphosis
kafka or
ovid i loved it he loves it oh
so that's the joke now you tell it oh
okay so
a professor walks into a rare books
collection no you've ruined it
no it's not funny look raymond a yellow
crested warbler look raymond a
yellow-crusted word
ugh not excited enough they may be
common but they're still
birds the 92nd street y had a wonderful
symposium on just that topic
that's it you're getting it ah
don't say cool instead say indeed oh
indeed indeed indeed
indeed indeed that's weird look raymond
a yellow-crusted warbler yes that's the
right level of excitement for such a
bird you captured the essence of kevin
you've done it correction i've
accomplished it indeed
indeed
it's growing on me i don't care for it
classical music
uh yeah i was ooh but now i'm back eh
meet me in the service corridor we've
got a situation with the hostages
okie dokie sorry to hear a boot that
service corridor that was great jake
thanks okay i'm approaching the drop
site i don't see anything unusual
we have eyes on you just be natural
indeed i will
oh look a yellow crusted warbler very
good
she's calling wait kevin we didn't go
over how you answer the phone there's in
time just answer
you've reached professor kevin cosner
please start speaking when i finish this
sentence
pick up the book on the bench and head
south
he hung up and he had me pick up a copy
of the tempest
oh no raymond do you know what's
happening in the park today the
shakespeare festival which will be
attended by
guys i'm in a sea of kevin's
you could've had a chopper raymond why
don't you take advantage just a minute
my cauldron's boiling over
yeah but what she actually said was
chopper's yours peralta
your impression was better damn it he's
still here excuse me hmm
uh i was just talking to another one of
the voices
is it tatiana who knows the mischievous
seven-year-old british girl you told me
about on the phone
may i speak with her uh
yes hello doctor
i'm from wasaks is that an actual place
in england how should i know i'm just a
little girl i
am i am well it's nice to speak with you
tatiana can i say hello to
brian the bookkeeper from central london
cheers i'm brian i like bookkeeping
right in the middle of london
did i tell you a full list of my old
many personalities when i called you on
the old telly in it
yes you did you know any of them
hopefully
not from england there's jeffrey you
said he's australian
oh crikey
well garrett our time is up shall we
pick up here next week
uh no i can't go there's still
someone left inside that wants to talk
do you mean satchel
the gentle african-american man who was
born in 1908.
oh no you know what satchel probably
shouldn't come out right now or ever for
that matter garrett
i can only help you if you open up
andy dufresne escaped through the
tunnels of shawshank
prison he was my friend
are you just doing morgan freeman ah
yes and you calling me on it just gave
me a major breakthrough i'm cured
anyway deuces doc all right sorry for
the delay
but i have some news i gotta say your
hazmat suit is super scary
you should talk in a silly voice so you
seem less terrifying well we ran our
test
see even that would be much less ominous
if you just did a grover voice well we
ran our tests and it's not baking powder
there's a chance it's toxic what
you